[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory the
World of Harry Potter is rif with
magical Mysteries and hidden connections
but one particular Enigma has left fans
puzzled for years in the third
installment of the series Harry Potter
and the Prisoner of aaban an unexpected
name appears on the infamous Marauders
map n's Commander this surprising
Revelation has sparked countless
theories and speculations among fans all
attempting to unravel the mystery behind
n's appearance on the map today we're
going to dive into the most intriguing
theories that attempt to explain why the
renowned mag zoologist known for his
adventures in the Fantastic be series
would find himself on the map of Hogwart
School of which craft and Wizardry
during Harry's time there I've done a
video on this in the past but it was
significant if iFly less developed with
fewer theories it was also 4 years ago
so I'm excited to take a look at this
topic again let's dive in the werewolf
issue how you might be wondering do
werewolves have anything to do with NES
Commander showing up at Hogwarts well
hear me out in the same year that n's
Commander can be seen on the map Remis
Lupin began his posting as the defense
against the dark arts professor at
Hogwarts in my eyes rumor lopin was
unquestionably the best defense against
the dark arts Professor he had a vast
knowledge of the dark arts and how to
defend against them but he was also an
excellent teacher he knew how to impart
his knowledge onto others in a
productive way balancing both Theory and
practical application to ensure that
when the time came his students would be
able to implement the magic he taught
but is the issue Remis Lupin was a
werewolf and what is NES Commander's
affiliation with werewolves well he
actually happened to be the founder of
the official were werewolf registry in
1947 a list of all known werewolves in
Great Britain the stigma in The
Wizarding World surrounding werewolves
is immense and from the moment you
contract lycanthropy it is almost
certain that you will never be treated
the same because of this lycanthropes
will often need to live a very solitary
lonely existence as allowing people to
become close to you only puts their
lives in danger because of the perceived
danger to those around them many
werewolves are asked to voluntarily
submit their name to the the werewolf
registry however few elected to put
their names down on the registry as it
only made their lives more difficult
lupin's name did not appear on the
registry and that's why there was such
an outcry from parents when the truth
finally came out at the end of prisoner
of aaban however despite all of this
lupin's hirer Dumbledore was aware of
the fact that Lupin was a werewolf
here's what I think may have happened
Dumbledore fully aware of rus' condition
but entirely willing to hire him decided
to consult with his old friend NES
commander who worked for the Department
for the regulation and control of
magical creatures by contacting n he
hoped to gain a better understanding of
werewolves and what risks hiring Remis
might have posed the students of
Hogwarts because n valued Dumbledore's
friendship and owed him a lot he never
exposed Dumbledore's actions to the
ministry but did warn Dumbledore that he
would have to keep careful watch of
Remis this explains his presence on the
Marauders map however as we all know
things invariably go wrong and Remis
ends up transforming into a werewolf on
the Hogwarts grounds we also know that
it's inevitably leaked to parents that a
werewolf is teaching their kids although
Snape is often credited for leaking this
information it's entirely possible that
n may have contributed as well
particularly as it would have been his
duty as head of the werewolf registry
this time tomorrow the owls will start
arriving from parents they will not want
a werewolf teaching their children Harry
and after last night I see their point I
could have bitten any of you that must
never happen again visiting Dumbledore
despite being expelled from Hogwarts n
was a favorite of then Transfiguration
teacher and now head Master Alber
Dumbledore after n's book was published
Dumbledore even went so far as to write
a raving review n's Masterpiece had been
an approved textbook at Hogwart School
of Witchcraft and Wizardry ever since
its publication and must take a
substantial amount of credit for our
students consistently h results in care
of magical creatures
examinations yet it is not a book to be
confined to the classroom no visiting
household is complete without a copy of
Fantastic Beasts well thumbed by the
generations who have rifled its pages in
search of the best way to rid the lawn
of Hawk lumps interpret the mournful
cries of the augre or cure their pet
puff skin of drinking out of the toilet
despite n's expulsion from Hogwarts new
and Dumbledore always remained very
close particularly as Dumbledore vly
tried to prevent him from being expelled
they had quite a deep friendship so it
makes sense that n would go to visit an
old friend his book was even part of the
Hogwarts curriculum this U perfectly
into my next Theory delivery given that
NES book fantastic beast and where to
find them was an approved part of the
Hogwarts curriculum and integral to the
care of magical creatures class it
stands to reason that n may have simply
been delivering copies of his books to
the school sure I know he's the author
and that he doesn't have to deliver
books I also know that he would have
been quite old at this stage but many
authors take great pride in their works
and it may have been an opportunity for
n to kill two birds with one stone
delivering some of his books while
visiting his old stomping ground glitch
one rather straight forward theory on
this topic suggests that it was simply a
glitch or anomaly in the Mar's map that
caused it to briefly display the name of
n's Commander the map despite its
intricate enchantments and advanced
magical nature may not always provide
complet completely accurate and
real-time information and the appearance
of n's name could be attributed to a
technical malfunction or a temporary
oversight within the map's functioning
the Marauders map originally created by
RIS Lupin Sirius Black Peter Pettigrew
and James Potter is a complex magical
artifact that relies on meticulous
enchantments and a deep understanding of
magic it allows the user to track the
movements of individuals within the
grounds of Hogwart School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry the magic used in the map's
creation is ADV aned and impressive it
includes the homonculus charm enabling
the possessor of the map to track the
movements of every person in the castle
and it was also Enchanted to Forever
repel as insultingly as possible the
Curiosity of their Nemesis Severus Snape
however what we do have to remember is
that this map fueled by highly Advanced
magic was created by a group of
school-age children powerful though they
were the Marauders were still comprised
of a bunch of wizards in their youth
furthermore by the the time n's name
appeared on the map it was nearly 20
years old technically speaking the map
has a lot of moving Parts it's highly
complex and it stands to reason that
after 20 years it may have started to
cause problems Buck beak the next theory
is that n was on the Hogwarts grounds to
help save Buck beak one of the key
events of the prisoner of aaban was the
execution of buck beak the hippogriff
Buck Beak was sentenced to death after
attacking Draco Malfoy during his first
care of magic creatures lesson where
Malfoy provoked him Hagrid later
explains to Harry Ron and Hermione that
buck Beek's death sentence was carried
out without a trial and was issued by
the ministry of Magic's committee for
the disposal of dangerous creatures
however it's worth noting that buck Beak
was not a dangerous creature he just had
an unfortunate altercation with a
student that was showing him disrespect
as a key event in the prison of asaman
it makes perfect sense that buck Beek's
imminent execution would draw n's
attention first of all n had a profound
love for all magical creatures secondly
new's own mother happened to be a
breeder of hippogryphs adding a more
personal touch to the situation and
lastly n did not believe in the
Injustice that was the execution of bug
beak n's belief that magical creatures
are not inherently dangerous but rather
react to mistreatment would motivate him
to travel to Hogwarts and defend
Buckbeak with his dedication to the
welfare magical creatures it is
reasonable to assume that n would make
every effort to prevent the unjust
execution leading to his appearance on
the Marauders map ral's Commander
remember Luna love good well in later
life she actually went on to become a
rather famous magu zoologist just like
new and what set her off on this career
path well I suspect it may have been
inspired by her social interactions with
a boy named Ralph because you see Ralph
who happened to be studying at Hogwarts
around the same time time as her was
actually the grandson of n's commander
and po pentina Goldstein interestingly
enough Luna actually went on to marry
Wolf's Commander n's grandson it has
been expressed for their wedding Luna
dressed in typical eccentric Luna
fashion sporting a rainbow dress and
tiara with unicorn horns they even went
on to have a couple of kids lson and
Lysander anyway my point is this given
that Ralph was within a couple of years
at Luna at Hogwarts it stands the reason
that new may have simply been paying
visit to his grandson and that's it for
this video If you enjoyed it please like
the video and subscribe to the channel
also if you want more content be sure to
check out my second Channel Harry Potter
Theory extra until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to
[Music]
live